Speaker 1: Let's go next to Nick from Long
Island. Nick from Long Island. You're on the air.
Speaker 4: So I wanted to ask you, since Democrats
aren't really caring about getting anything done
right now, like lowering prescription
drug prices because of the roadblocks
that we face in the Senate and the fact that Biden
Speaker 2: can can try to
Speaker 4: use pressure politics, do you think
Democrats actually care about winning in 2022?
Since, like, they're not
like getting anything done,
Speaker 1: so I don't know that I
would characterize the situation
the way you're characterizing it. I mean,
to speak specifically about prescription
Speaker 2: drugs build back better
Speaker 1: actually has a bunch of
prescription drug stuff in it, including limiting
out-of-pocket insulin costs through insurance
to $35 a month, which is major just in and
of itself given the number of people with
diabetes in the United States. I agree with
you, generally speaking, that the Democrats
are not getting enough done, and there needs to be
Speaker 2: some other major
Speaker 1: policy
Speaker 2: accomplishment to be able
Speaker 1: to point
Speaker 2: to in order
Speaker 1: to justify people voting for
Democrats in 2022. And on whether Democrats
care about winning in 2022. I do think there are
some Democrats who have been given the numbers and
they've been shown here's what's going on with
redistricting. Here's what's going on in this.
We're going to lose the House in 2022 and some
may have given up. I don't and I disagree with
that position, but I don't know that it's
that they don't care. I just I think I
Speaker 2: just see that all of the situation
Speaker 1: a little bit differently than you.
Speaker 4: Yeah, well, you know, another big issue
that I hear a lot on, like shows like, right? They
talk about how, you know, they say legalized
bribery has something to do with not getting
popular provisions done. And it just seems to
me like like corporations really want Democrats
to lose elections because Republicans would
it would make sense because Republicans would
easily just grant them more tax cuts.
Speaker 2: Don't you think so? Not.
Speaker 1: It's not as cut and dry. There are
lots of large corporations that understand
Speaker 2: that the
Speaker 1: economic policies of Democrats
are more demand side stimulus rather than trickle
down supply side stuff, and they know that those
things are good for them. Many corporations
realize if everybody makes a little more money
Speaker 2: we now have, we now have
Speaker 1: customers with a little
bit more money, which they can spend here
like that's a demand side stimulus economic
Speaker 2: idea. And the truth is,
Speaker 1: for most of most corporations,
they're not really. Most corporations are
not political in the sense of the corporation
is liberal or conservative. They're trying
to do what's best for them, and often it's
hedging their bets by donating to both sides.
I mean, that's the reality of it. You look at
cable ISPs and cable companies. You look at,
Speaker 2: you know, big food. Most of these
Speaker 1: companies are donating some to both
sides so that they can have friends in power, no
Speaker 2: matter who wins.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I think
that pretty much answers my my questions.
Speaker 1: All right. Nick from Long Island,
thanks very much. Appreciate the call.